what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and today I will be
breaking down the insane twists that
just took place in the boku no hero
story including an unexpected time skiff
that could be the beginning of the
biggest and most intense war arc in the
history of boku no hero we just learned
the true nature of Nana she Morris quark
and we got some shocking information
about what's about to happen in the
story so let's get into it if you
enjoyed the boku no hero content on this
channel and you want to see more please
leave a like to let me know and if you
happen to be new to anime uproar don't
forget to subscribe and hit that
notification bell to turn on all
notifications if you want to get
notified and not have YouTube hiding our
videos from you then you have to go
through the process of clicking the
notification bell and then clicking off
the option that says all you can also
hit me up on Twitter and Instagram at
anime uproar for all the latest boku no
hero news and updates
finally this chapter will of course
include boku no hero manga spoilers
we're talking about the very latest
happenings in the manga so please
proceed with caution you have been
warned ever since black whip started to
manifest within him and ever since he
learned that he would be manifesting the
quirks of the other previous one for all
users deku has been doing his best to
master black whip while also researching
all of the other previous one for all
users we know that one for all comes
from all for one's brother who had a
latent quirk inside of him that allowed
him to pass quirks on to someone else
after all for one transferred a
stockpiling quirk into his brother the
stockpiling quirk combined with the
brothers transferring quirk in order to
create what we know today as one for all
but as hard as he's been trying Deku has
been unable to find a single clue or
piece of information about the two one
for all users who came after all for
one's brother
there is just no information on record
about the second and third one for all
users and all might believes that this
is primarily because the previous users
would have had no idea that their quirk
factors could be retained within one for
all and passed on to future generations
if they had known that their quirks
would have been used
the future they likely would have left
some helpful information for future one
for all users but along with his
research deku has also been working hard
to tame and master the already
manifested new quirk known as black whip
he still can't use it for more than a
second but even with his limited mastery
of the new quirk deck who is able to use
it for support black whip has made deku
more agile and it has increased his
range of potential attacks which I'm
sure is going to prove to be extremely
useful in the near future the name of
black whips original user was Dai Goro
Banjo whose hero name was a lariat for
his part but Google isn't too impressed
with the previous one for all users
since none of them had the kind of
reputation that all might have they were
not known to stand at the top of the
hero world as fearless symbols of peace
and order because the previous one for
all users were just a bunch of nobodies
from Paco's perspective he is skeptical
that these previous users had quirks
that were particularly strong or useful
however almond explains that in the past
when all for one was at the height of
his power he would simply stomp out all
strong heroes before they ever had a
chance to shine and become famous for
their powers and heroic deeds the
previous users of one for all were not
the chosen ones they were not
celebrities or internationally
recognized heroes they were just noble
people who did their best to fight
against evil and who willingly gave
their lives in battle against all-4-one
as decos research shows all of the
previous users died rather young which
demonstrates just how much sacrifice was
required to fight against all-4-one back
in those days when he was at the height
of his power when Bakugan and deckle
wonder what will be the next quirk that
Deku will need to master all might
reveals that it will be his masters
quirk his master was of course
Shigure Aki's grandmother Nana Shimura
and the name of her quark was float as
the name suggests this quirk allowed
Nana to basically float in midair
although he can't be sure if she was
able to straight-up fly through the air
at great speeds like say Superman or if
she was able to just kind of hover above
the ground when he hears this Paco is
not impressed at all he says that he can
already flow
using his explosions so this just means
the deco is going to have to waste his
time learning to do something that Paco
already knows how to do
Bakugan finds this to be an exciting
prospect since it will give him a chance
to pull ahead of Deku in terms of skill
and ability while Deku is busy trying to
master a skill that baklava has already
mastered baka will have time to work on
other skills and pull ahead of Deku in
terms of overall ability but Baku goes
rivalry with Deku aside if you've been
paying attention to the last few arcs of
the boku no hero story then you know
exactly why the ability to float could
prove to be extremely useful for Deku in
fact this ability could save deck whose
life don't forget that shigaraki
recently awakened his own quirk decay
and decay now allows him to quickly
destroy not only the objects or people
that he touches but also everything and
everyone who is physically connected to
his intended target so for example if
she gareki decides to use his quirk on
the street he could disintegrate
everyone who happens to be on the street
at that time he could also disintegrate
the buildings and other objects that are
located on that street and so on but
simply if you are in physical contact
with anything that is in physical
contact with shigaraki
target his decay can spread to you and
destroy you if you have the ability to
float up into the air then you will no
longer be connected to the street or
anything else that she gareki's quirk
may be targeting and that means that you
will be safe from the rapidly spreading
destruction of shi gerecke's newly
awakened quirk so with that said we know
that even just being able to float in
midair would be extremely useful and
potentially life-saving for Deku in a
battle against shigaraki but if Nana's
quirk also allows her to move freely
through the air on top of just floating
then Deku will basically become Superman
he would have super strength super speed
and agility and he would have the
ability to fly if that were the case I'm
not sure how I feel about it to be
honest
I always thought that the modern
iteration of Superman was too old P
while most other heroes have one special
ability
Superman pretty much has them all so I
wouldn't want that
to become that broken but we will have
to wait and see what happens
as class 1-a celebrates new year and the
start of the final semester of their
first year at UA all mine in Iowa have a
brief discussion outside in the cold
Iowa confirms the next week he will
begin training
arrey to control her work and all might
offers to help the two teachers then
discuss all meit's perspective on life
and how he now feels helpless he wishes
that he could help the students even
more and be there for them but in his
current state and being retired rather
than an active duty pro hero there is
only so much than ohm I can do he had
grown accustomed to being able to
accomplish virtually anything and he was
recognized throughout the country as the
greatest hero and the symbol of peace
but now the situation has changed and
all might find it difficult to adjust
but Iowa tells all mine that just by
being alive and being here for the
students he is giving them the strength
and motivation to succeed all might
might be retired now and much weaker
than he was before but his incredible
heroic deeds are still widely recognized
and celebrated he is still a source of
inspiration for so many people so even
though he is weaker he is by no means
useless as the conversation between the
two teachers ends we learned at Sioux
kouchi ask either all might or Aizawa to
tell the other that they will have to
postpone their plan to visit stain it
was unclear to me which of the
characters was speaking at this time so
it's either all might was planning to
visit stain for some reason or Aizawa
was since all mine in Sioux kouchi are
in regular contact and I saw is
currently interested in any information
you could find on kudo giddy it would
make sense to me that Iowa was the one
who wanted to meet with stain and see if
he learned anything about kudo giddy in
his interactions with the league of
villains but it could also be that
Almighty wants to speak to stain for
some unspecified reason we don't get any
more information than that so we don't
know why one of them wants to meet with
stain and we also don't know why the
visit has to be postponed but I have to
say that I do like the fact that stain
is being mentioned again it's been a
while since we've heard anything from
him or about him then seemingly out of
nowhere we went
a time-skip occur as the cherry blossoms
begin to sprout and we find ourselves in
late March which is roughly three months
later we see the mysterious and sinister
villain dr. Daruma Fujiko walking the
halls of a hospital one of the nurses
recognizes him but she behaves as if you
gqo hasn't been to the hospital in some
time the doctor is apparently a rare
sight at the hospital which makes sense
since we know that he's been quite
preoccupied with his freelance research
but it seems that despite his
extracurricular activities Fujiko is
still an active doctor and he is still
recognized by the nurses at the hospital
not long ago
Alberto mentioned the hospital as a clue
twice away and present Mike about what
really happened before he lost
consciousness so it is safe to assume
that you Chico's presence at the
hospital now could be related to these
recent events about Fudo Guinea it's
clear that kuru kitty must have been
created by all from one energy co and
the confirmation that you G Co still has
active access to the hospital proves
that he would have had access to all
Burroughs body back when he was injured
and seemingly killed
I say seemingly because it could turn
out that he wasn't really dead just on
the brink of death but if all of this
wasn't enough in terms of twists and
drama the final page of chapter 257
offers yet another shocking twist the
final page says that day heroes vanished
from the city that's a pretty crazy way
to end the chapter and potentially a
massive development what exactly do
these words mean how and why did all of
the heroes from a major city vanish the
craziest answer would be that all the
heroes have been eliminated by the
villains thanks to shigga Rocky's new
power which he received after undergoing
fujiko's crazy procedure and now that ug
Co has decided to make a public
appearance at the hospital it must mean
that he is ready to put his master plan
into action if all the pro heroes in an
entire major city were somehow
eliminated then we're looking at a
villain attack of epic proportions
something that will completely change
the game in the boku no hero
Corie since the students of ua are not
technically considered pro heroes we can
assume that they would still be safe in
this scenario but even if that is the
case the idea that the villains would be
able to eliminate all the pro heroes
inside a major city would move us way
beyond anything we've seen before it
will be the start of an all-out war
between the hero society and the
paranormal Liberation Front this would
not be just any villain attack or action
the Japanese government would not be
able to ignore something like this and
the entire hero society would have to
declare war on the villains but as epic
and game changing as that would be we
have to acknowledge that the fact that
the heroes managed may not mean that
they were all literally killed it could
also mean something else
such as the villains creating a massive
diversion outside of the city that
forces all of the heroes to respond and
leave the city
unguarded then having lured the heroes
away from the city
the villains could then proceed to make
some major evil move inside the city
itself if we think back to soo cauchy's
message that the visit to stayin in
Tartarus prison would have to be
postponed we might even be looking at a
major Prison Break taking place the kind
of massive Prison Break that could force
as many heroes as possible to respond
and leave an entire city unprotected but
whatever is about to happen there is no
doubt that it will be big shigaraki has
successfully completed huge eCos
procedure a new gqo is convinced that
the procedure worked and that shigaraki
has become his masterpiece this occurred
back in chapter 2 v 5 so knowing how
strong she Guara key is now knowing that
all-4-one in huge ago have been plotting
something big for a long time
knowing that Hawkes has also been
plotting something for a very long time
and knowing that the paranormal
Liberation Front is now stronger than
ever it is safe to assume that we are
about to transition into a major hero
versus villain war are probably the
first true war arc in the boku no hero
story I'm extremely excited about this
and also kind of scared that some of our
favorite characters might actually die
in this arc but we'll have to wait and
see let me know what you guys think
how do you feel about the reveal of
Nana's quark float and do you think that
it just allows the user to hover in the
air or does it allow them to fly through
the air at will also what do you think
that the final page of chapter 257
really means what is would you go up to
and where did all the heroes go be sure
to give me your thoughts and feedback
down in the comments below
if you enjoyed this video you want to
see more boku no hero content right here
on the channel please leave a like to
let me know it really does help and if
you happen to be new to anime uproar
don't forget to subscribe and hit that
notification bell to turn on all
notifications feel free to hit me up on
Twitter and Instagram at anime uproar
and a big thank you to all of our anime
uproar patrons for making videos like
this one possible with all the YouTube
problems lately patron support is more
important than ever so thank you guys so
much special thanks to all of our pro
hero tier patrons including the one and
only Gilgamesh nothing but a fan Jason
Wilson Kings ell drous fitty dolla beat
Anatoli kazansky alpha deal on hell Cruz
team Sparky 65 cricket XP Rohan Kapoor
Jessica Maloney and Emperor otaku and I
can't forget the ones that rise above
all other clans a massive thank you to
all of our the wanna tier patrons
including in grata a Lola nada
makoto-kun the world stealers the school
bus and Tyson Queenie no if you enjoy
our work and you feel that it provides
value to you please consider supporting
us on patreon even a single dollar will
give you access to our patron exclusive
discord and your name will appear on our
videos along with these legendary people
as always thank you guys so much for
watching and until next time see us bass
Cowboys
[Music]